the idea that we might as the expression
has it lose touch with our feelings is
when we reflect on it a highly
paradoxical one
how could we lose touch with feelings
that belong to us where might they go
and what might be driving their loss
it seems we're built in such a way that
an understanding of much of what our
minds and our bodies go through is in no
way automatic it is mediated via the
acceptance and understanding of other
people we know well enough about some
things if for example there were to be a
gaping wound in our leg or we hadn't
drunk anything for three days we would
know the truth soon enough
but many of our sensations are like
bells that have no solid wire back to
consciousness they ring at a peculiar
frequency that isn't picked up by our
minds when these have been attuned
incorrectly
this may for example happen around
tiredness
our body may have grown extremely weary
over many years but consciousness might
simply not be interested because it's
been calibrated to respond only to an
agenda which sets store by the
fast-paced pursuit of status and money
or we might feel hugely anxious or in a
rage with someone but consciousness
might not care because we have been
ordered to be confident or extremely
good
or there might be a profound sadness
inside us but the feeling might not earn
our attention because we're meant to be
privileged people with nothing to
complain about
why do we overlook our feelings like
this because we generally only notice
those feelings to which other people
especially people in our childhoods pay
attention to
and conversely ignore those which they
sideline or belittle if no one
especially cares that we are worried if
the grounds for our anger would be
refused immediately if there's a
dominant assumption that tiredness is
for wimps then we'll follow suit and
disdain bits of ourselves as much as
others have done
knowing how to care for ourselves
depends on having been cared for by
others
we listen to ourselves because people
around us have listened to us
reconnecting with our lost feelings
therefore relies on a new expanded sense
of what it might be legitimate to
experience we have to be given
permission to give our attention to as
much of the sorrow anxiety anger or
tiredness as may really be locked inside
us
put another way we have to be loved
properly and so allowed to register
whatever we are actually going through
without being belittled stonewalled or
humiliated
love will allow us to enjoy what should
always have been our basic privilege
to know what we feel
our emotional barometer is a tool that
can help us to more clearly explain our
moods
click the link on screen now to find out
more
you